um
back then like when the gangster girls
are hot hottest [ __ ] right
could a label pay you to do it like like
let's say it was an artist that was
you didn't know about could they cut the
stimulus check most of it and he did
plenty of times
what's you gotta think too the time i
mean
it may be a little different now but
even there are artists
like yo gotti's an example of that like
the first tape we did together
he paid me and he was he had just got
signed so these are still artists that
are
like you know we know of today you know
what i'm saying that the labels were
still cutting checks for
so it would it would it would vary like
they would come from all
avenues would you about to ask though i
was gonna say what was the biggest uh
what like what's the
like what was the the going rate um
it got up to like 25 30 000.
damn like a tape yeah it was crazy yeah
and then like
so give me like so like so something
like the little brother gangsta grills
right
which was so dope because little
brother's obviously from the south
right but they kind of you know it's
crazy because back then
i feel like we really separated types of
hip hop 100
so much more than we do now yeah they
told me it wasn't going to make sense
when i did that
like now like people can work with each
other and
people don't even bat an eye at it back
then like i like remember like how how
crazy it was like
when you heard talib quality and jay-z
on a song together absolutely
like and so you do there's a lot of that
kanye had a lot to do
but you doing the gangster girl's a
little brother right was that your idea
was that the label coming in
no that had no that was me and little
brother i mean i was i had been a fan
like i'm
we're hip-hop heads too so you know i'm
saying i've been a little brother fan
and when i remember we wound up we ran
into each other they had a show at yin
yang cafe here in atlanta and i went to
go see him
and we we talked about it on the bus and
and it's
looking back on it like again little
brother tape and the pharrell tape
like when i did those tapes crazy like
though at the time gangster girls was
still known
for like t-i-g-z wayne bunby so it was
it had a certain you know style to it or
it was like
street music you know what i'm saying so
i remember people being like you're
gonna do it gangsters with who
little brother pharrell and i was like
watch this and you know like
even for me like that was getting back
to my roots to be able to do something
with them you know what i'm saying so
they you know them being a fan and me
being a fan it was like it was
it was perfect like i was so excited to
do those tapes too to really just start
branching out and going
different directions too with the brand
yeah and then like how many like so okay
like you mentioned the um the pharrell
tape which is [ __ ]
so fire and then actually ghost dj that
hole too oh you did okay okay
but i'm just curious like he was on the
road
uh questionable i have questionable
turntables
you and uh pharrell like you decided to
do it against the grills does he just
handle all the creative or are you
sending him ideas beats
it was both we're sending him ideas and
beats and um
he was he had a phenomenal uh
uh outline of where he wanted to go with
it he definitely picked some incredible
beats and we gave him
some and um you know and i what i used
to do is i used to write out a script
i used to have a script and it basically
was like literally like me interviewing
the artist
and that would kind of give me a formula
for the tape so you know that's when i
used to do interludes and
talk and chop it up you know just kind
of piecing those stuff that stuff
together like um
so so yeah i mean and again you know i
met i met pharrell
when tip was on house arrest um like
before we did down with the king
so we had we had got acquainted then
you know so he was familiar with me
early on in my like
in that part of my career so then you
know he kind of touched back and was
like yo
i love what you're doing like we got to
do one i mean to this day it's the only
mixtape he's ever done you know and it's
just you know it's being fan like it was
monumental
like i know that that's just that's a
tape too like
you know i meet a lot of kids today not
even kids anymore but you know they'll
be like yo that pharrell gang like
the same way like uh the jeezy and a
wayne tape is to
to some that's how you know a different
uh cloth is to the
to the pharrell tape percent you know
what i'm saying so yeah all classics we
got nothing but [ __ ] classics under
our belts
your [ __ ] talk that [ __ ]